[BIRDS TWEET]
Oh, is it me?
OK, uh-- um.
[CHEERING]
No.
OK.
This is a story about--
um, about--
[JAZZY SHOW MUSIC]
Oh!
It's-- it's a song.
Can you do it?
This is your idea.
Right, but you're better at the singing, so--
Everyone here hates me.
Can you please, please--
Just do it.
(SINGING) Here's a little ditty about Pretty Penny, left home
for the city.
She was one of many.
Got letters by the sack from her lonely father.
But did she write him back?
No, she didn't bother.
Got one last letter.
And the letter said, we're sorry to inform you
that your father's dead.
Dead!
Dead, dead, dead, dead, dead, dead!
(SINGING) So talk to daddy.
Talk, talk to daddy.
He will rock you when you are sad.
He isn't ideal, but you need to heal.
So talk to daddy.
Talk, talk to daddy now.
Talk to Daddy!
Talk, talk to Daddy!
Talk, talk to Daddy now!
(SINGING) Here is what I know about Local Lenny.
He was low on the dope.
Well, he hadn't any.
His wealthy Pa said, I'll help you,.
Sonny but Lenny said, nah, I don't need your money.
A few months passed.
He was passed out in the gutter.
If you got real close, you could hear him mutter.
Mutter.
Mutter, mutter, mutter, mutter, father!
So talk to Daddy.
Talk, talk to Daddy.
He will rock you when you are sad.
He left you alone, but maybe he's grown.
So talk to Daddy.
Talk, talk to Daddy.
Odds are you are gonna outlive him,
so you really ought to forgive him.
There's a chance that he's homicidal.
But the bond between you is vital.
Odds are you are gonna to outlive him,
so you really ought to forgive him.
There's a chance that he's homicidal,
but the bond between you is vital.
Dooby da da, dooby da da, dooby da da Daddy.
Dooby da da, dooby da da dooby da da, Daddy.
Daddy!
[INSTRUMENTAL INTERLUDE]
[PHONE RINGS]
Talk.
Daddy.
Talk, Daddy.
Talk, talk, talk, talk.
Talk to Daddy.
Talk, talk to Daddy.
He will rock you when you are sad.
He may be insane, but you are in pain, so talk to daddy.
Talk, talk to daddy now.
Now!